any one of mine suckers gonna come and
crush this class of way better so I'm
really really excited well I almost
wanted to tell me that to go up and
start teaching this so should I go and
learn the Botox Juvederm class and do
your makeup class happy vacation whoo
All Stars All Stars here All Stars
[Music]
our I believe nation welcome to day
three of our creepy and adventure I
realized it didn't update you on what
was happening last night so we got back
on the boat I mean basically just
crashed I skipped dinner what Nina
bought me a bunch of bread which is what
I eat so I had fresh cookies and bread
yes happy vacation whoo I'm feeling
better today I slept a lot I was in bed
all late afternoon and evening I guess
head fever but feeling better feeling
better now
go eat a bunch of crap right now you're
gonna get a gentle be gentle today's our
day at sea so we're gonna look through
the itinerary see what see what there is
to do and take you guys on their ID with
us let's go we're vlogging Ritchie where
are you
where's your blog Aidan who's Peyton's
legend I like it
I really want to come mother
pancakes and bacon and maple syrup all
the yummy food these guys don't have but
you're gonna play it safe with some
cereal and almond milk try not thinking
ahead stomach today what did you get mr.
cereal me too
how the Cheerios let's see what son nina
picked for us to do today fitness class
when we miss that Zumba at 10:00 okay
ballroom dance class salsa Nina wants to
learn salsa Nina I think you know to
leave that class what Elsa she margov D
or makeup master class facial workshop
Botox and Juvederm okay spirit of taste
try before you buy
Greek goose tasting celebrity Showtime
so it looks like a lot of Nina centric
activities okay so should I go to learn
the Botox Juvederm class and do your
makeup class so you're not gonna go to
them we'll see I have to find my own
things to do today I think let's see
what Nina dark here she is
light light Wow I don't know how light
that is Bob he's pretty good I'm missing
mushrooms what's around two for Haven
oh all right now like that
Nina's back she's back for round two
eating late today eating late today what
do we got oh we got fruit vegetables and
vacant light okay so I dropped the kids
off at the kids program leave them there
for a couple hours and Nina and the
cousins are gonna go salsa dancing it
says new dance that we haven't heard of
called salsa we're gonna see what kind
of music :
all right Nina hi had some fun we should
try this whole salsa thing when we get
home maybe sign up for a class - yeah it
was fun but you know what it's always
great doing these lessons because it
reminds me of how much my instructors
are amazing any one of my instructors
gonna come and crush this class way
better so I'm really really excited well
I almost wanted to tell Nina to go up
and start teaching us she is
[Music]
the kids want to go play ping-pong
they're going swimming after lunch in
King Kong right now and the blog for
Richie continues yeah
they found it what was that All Stars
All Stars here All Stars
[Music]
all right we had a few moments of
relaxation there did you can't Antonina
okay look at my shoulder he was getting
a tan on I watched some league of
legends games catch up watch some news
and now we're gonna get some lunch
are you hungry I'm not hungry I played
some more bread that's all I've eaten
today
more bread but gotta keep the stomach we
get too upset so lunchtime
I really want to try to butter chicken
pizza or put enough squash it says but
instead I have a slice of bread oh nice
what are you eating Richie Havens got
his ice cream on looks like vanilla with
caramel sauce and M&Ms oh the wife
decided to get me some yummy pasta with
no sauce so when upset my stomach Thank
You Nina
we love you thank you for thinking of us
lunch is done stomach is getting a
little upset so I'm gonna go lie down
Nina's gonna go check out jewelery stuff
she didn't want to say it
but Nina's gonna go look from jewelry
step to bed
[Music]
so it's just past 6:30 came back to the
room crashed pretty hard you me she
crashed that had a nap she's off to have
dinner with the kids and the rest of the
family the sea is moving a lot so I'm
staying on lower grounds to hopefully
rest up I did have a massive plate of
crackers decent for the stomach
I hope so I'm gonna get to work done I'm
gonna review the clips for the YouTube
channel maybe record a couple clips if
not today then tomorrow and get things
ready the work must continue awesome
videos must be posted to the new channel
so that's what my night's gonna look
like well Nina's up having dinner it's
also Nina's birthday coming up in a
couple days I get head the spa and see
if I can organize something for us to do
as a special birthday surprise while
she's stopping dinner I got it
papers in hand got a deep tissue massage
for 50 minutes in the couple's room so I
asked him not to send the confirmation
to the room so that Nina does not find
out
they're pretty excited she's gonna like
it just been a lot of pain recently
so hopefully the massage helps and she
has happy birthday Lina's back from
dinner
how you doing me too much so what you
gonna go do now does that make sense
all right all right I'll stay here I'm
gonna keep working on the YouTube
channel have a good time drink for both
of us don't come back
alcoholic okay love you have fun I got
some good YouTube video research done
super pumped for the new series that are
coming out but getting hungry so I'm
gonna head up to the dining language see
what kind of easy to digest bread and
meat pasta there's up there
[Music]
this is what I really want but I'm gonna
be happy if my stomach if I do alright
here it is I got some peas white rice
and peas a bunch of crackers olive roll
and some other car be whatever those
things are happy dinner look we just
came back
how you feeling how's the vodka drink
that water
[Music]
okay it's just past eleven o'clock
getting ready for bed it was not the
most eventful day even shaking her head
but tomorrow hopefully I'm gonna feel
hundred percent we've got a big day
lined up going to Costa Maya in doing
Ariel Park so doing some water slides
doing some zip lines the kids were
really looking forward to it I'm hoping
that my stomach will be a hundred
percent and I can eat real food and do
exciting things with the wife this young
man survived so thank you for joining us
for another day we believe in you hope
you two need to believe in yourself and
remember your one word is he doesn't
want to turn in much love what's easy